after the train journey comes another
long walk these refugees come from Syria
they're in Greece and are hoping to
cross the border here and reach
Macedonia
it's a journey into the unknown there's
a there's police there they didn't allow
to that people the group is growing all
the time those who do get stopped by the
police simply try again
their determination fueled by the hope
of a better life just do some new stuff
for what I can get in Europe but just on
yourself I hope so
they've been walking for more than an
hour then some good news this is our
location we are inside now inside
makedonia this is the from here they
want to find the train station at Java
literature but even with the help of GPS
the best way is under dispute
in the end the group opts for the longer
route so they can avoid the police as
night falls they come across an army
post anxiety is growing but a new law
allows them to travel through Macedonia
and they can even get official papers
that allow us to use train and general
transportation so tomorrow morning at 5
o clock we can take a tree into scoopy
or Kumanovo during the evening more
refugees join the group they come from
the many crisis regions that border
Europe early in the morning the train is
waiting the next destination the Serbian
border for many it's not their first
attempt a year ago
once North he got locked 40 days in jail
and I got locked 10 days in jail in
Egypt
every day crowds of refugees turn up at
the java literature train station here
on the Macedonian border many from
countries as far away as Sudan and
Somalia the journey to the Serbian
border takes three hours the regional
train is already packed but every
station brings new arrivals
on board the train there's an implicit
understanding among the refugees they
take it in turns to take a break and sit
down then finally the border station
comma novel another leg of the journey
is done I'm happy we're out of Macedonia
but it's only a temporary reprieve the
next frontier is yet to come